you know who i really [ __ ] with who
carrot top
oh didn't he go on joe rogan's show yeah
i watched the whole thing it was [ __ ]
awesome
yeah he's awesome i heard it was
hilarious yeah i mean he's yeah he's a
really funny b just like a sweet guy it
seems like
dude we gotta get it my only impression
of him is
is us making fun of him for that video
of his like dick falling out or whatever
and then
and then us
oh no i watched a video remember i
watched like one of his sets on conan or
something like that and i was like he's
actually pretty funny yeah i never heard
him speak or anything that was my only
impression so then jumping into this
episode i was like
i'm just curious what is he like
really nice guy down to earth it seems
dude
let's hit him up
i think we should i we joked about this
last year but like actually like
put it
mark it down boys
we gotta get carrot top on the ship and
pressure us to do it so if we don't do
it or talk or say any updates about it
or anything like comment be like dude
when's carrot top coming on
it would be
some legendary ass [ __ ]
he's been he's been doing comedy in
vegas in vegas alone
for like 17 years or something he said
he's at a residency
like
insane
or more than that it was like 21 years
it was crazy it was like yeah i've done
seven years at
the
luxor and then before i was at mgm it
was eight years and then
one year before that just like dipping
my toes and like when he started i guess
it was
him his show was like he had like dinner
booths and stuff so people were like
eating
at his show like he just
grinded
damn like that was his first year in
vegas people like it was like a dinner
show
oh so there's booths where you couldn't
even see in
to the people and they were eating not
even paying attention to what he was
saying and he's just up there like a
prop burlesque show basically yeah
yeah
hey
yeah damn
and now i wonder what the capsize on his
room is now
thousands i think
2 500 or something like that i think he
said that that's wild yeah you know what
i learned recently he's worth like 80
million or something like that
what yeah
he's [ __ ] mega rich
dude [ __ ] writing jokes
i'm bringing props on stage yeah i know
[ __ ] would anyone else has the prop
comedies hack
hack your way into some bored apes
that's what you can do
[Music]
damn you i only learned recently that
the blue man group it's not the same
blue men that perform everywhere
i don't believe that i think i
definitely knew that did you think it
was the same guys
yeah dude come on
so you probably think marshmallow is the
same dude too every night yeah
wait he's not
that's the second
like coming of age moment is when you
realize marshmallow is not real
no it's when you realize the blue man
group is is paid actors and blue man
group
no because all these kids are vibe in a
marshmallow concert they're like
marshmallows my favorite dj and then
some somewhere along the way you turn
18 and someone's like
well you still listen to marshmallow you
know it's like not actually one guy
right it's like a brand
and they're like what
yeah
and then they look at it they look at
this
they look at this door flyer and it's
365 cities on the same day
but
no
bro
you think santa claus hits all those
houses in one night
i mean i knew
santa wasn't real but marshmallow
i've been to like 10 of his shows and
you're telling me maybe that was just a
random
guy or what
you got me [ __ ] up
it's kind of crazy man that he has
achieved that the same level as santa
claus
yeah you know what i mean like
if you yeah if you told a kid too early
that that's just a dude in a helmet
that would be
soul-crushing man
was not
that's so funny yeah that's what they
think
yeah it's not the fact that it's a
different guy it's that it's a human
yeah yeah they're like what do you mean
it's not a
it's not a dude with a marshmallow face
wait that's a small face
what
[Laughter]
oh my
god marshmallow's not real
that's the shirt that we gotta make
marshmallow's not real
no man
marsha's a nice guy man
he's a nice guy we know the real
marshman yeah i met him one time yeah
helmet was on though
i mean he was still fully in the suit i
mean we could be a big he might be a
marshmallow he might be talking
marshmallow actually can you imagine you
reach out to him like man take that [ __ ]
off and you pull it and like
you're like
oh damn oh [ __ ] sorry man
his real eyes come through like the
black x's and his real mad like it's
like it's mass scary you [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my neck
i wouldn't try to pull your head off
would i [ __ ] psycho
you